[MUSIC PLAYING]
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to our talk
on Cloud Tasks,
point-to-point asynchronous
tasks across microservices.
My name is Vinod.
I am a product
manager at Google.
And I am co-presenting this
talk with Braden Bassingthwaite,
who's a chief architect
at Vendasta, and Bart
Hazer, who is an engineering
manager at Google.
A quick housekeeping
note, all of you
who have been attending
the conference,
and we have a Dory for
question and answers.
So as the talk
goes along, please
feel free to add your
questions on the Dory,
and we'll answer it at
the end of the talk.
So let's get started.
So here's a brief
agenda on the talk.
We're going to give
you a brief overview
on the journey of
building applications
from monoliths to microservices.
And then in that
journey, why there's
a need for building a
task queue in the process.
And then eventually
we're going to talk
about Vendasta's journey
with Google Cloud Tasks.
And then talk about the salient
features of the product.
And then probably a quick demo.
And then wrap up with Q&A.
So the first phase
of the journey
from building applications from
monoliths to microservices.
Consider building a simple image
rendering ML application where
you have a web app running
a couple of modules,
such as a rendering module
and a retrieval module,
and a user comes in and,
say, uploads an image, say,
for example, a cat image.
And then you run some rendering
work, process that image,
detect that it's a cat,
frame it, and store it
in the back-end.
And then retrieve the image,
and then say, hey, I'm a cat,
it's detected and so on.
If you build this on a
traditional web server
with a bunch of
modules, we have what we
call a monolithic application.
While building
these applications,
we may end up with
certain problems.
And the challenges with
such an application,
or limitations in
such an approach,
is that we may have
scalability issues.
It's difficult to scale
independent components,
such as the rendering module
or the retrieval module
independently.
It's hard to scale these modules
on independent dimensions,
such as, for example,
just CPU or memory.
Further, you have slower
developer velocity.
What it may face
here is that you
can't do continuous
deployment, you
have to redeploy your
entire application,
furthermore, you have
a large monolithic code
base, which is
difficult to maintain,
and it prevents teams from
working independently.
Additionally, you're
also committing yourself
to a long term technology stack.
Now, if you were to rewrite
the same application using
microservices, where you
had the same image rendering
application, but you had
two independent services,
a rendering service and
a retrieval service,
and the user comes in, uploads
a cat image, it goes back,
it's rendered, stored in
the back-end, and retrieved.
Now, each service
operates independently.
And there are certain benefits
of building an application
in this fashion.
The first is that you
have better scalability.
You can isolate hot services
and scale them independently.
Services can be scaled on
independent dimensions,
such as CPU and memory.
Further, you have faster
developer velocity.
It supports
continuous deployment.
Your code base can be organized
by each independent service.
Thereby, allowing you to
isolate these services
for testing and deployment.
And additionally, it
enables your teams
to work independently
and be more productive.
Lastly, it has a
shorter term commitment
to the same technology stack.
So building an application
in such a microservices
architecture, you may have
certain additional needs.
One of the key needs
is having a task queue.
So why do you need a task queue?
For example, if you go back
to the same image rendering
application, and suppose
your rendering service
was rendering 100 images,
and say, in a single loop.
Imagine if there is a failure
in even one of the images,
then you have
chances of failure,
your application
could break and so on.
This could lead to
higher user latency.
Further, you have
lesser guarantees
of making sure your images
get actually rendered.
And a single point
of failure can
break your entire application.
Now, if you were to just change
this and fork off the rendering
tasks to a queue and make the
queue process to work for you
to minimize user latency
and isolate failures
of, say, a single image,
and also, give you
a guarantee of at
least one execution,
you're making sure that
your application gives
the right level of service to
your users with the right level
of reliability guarantees.
Think of this as
like just the way
you would fork off threads
while writing your application
in any programming language,
and now you're just doing that
as threads for microservices.
So that is the motivation
for having a task queue when
you write up microservices.
So now, if you take
this a step further,
and you had many services,
like a user authentication
service along with the rendering
service and image upload
service, each of
these services could
upload independent tasks,
or asynchronous tasks,
to your queue.
One of them can say,
hey, when the user
is logging in for
the first time,
kick off certain
deferred emails that can
be sent a month later for
registration purposes.
You can have your
image rendering task
submitted as well to
the same task queue,
and each of these
services can then
consume the end results of
these tasks accordingly.
By doing this, this
task queue let's
these services interact
in a more different way,
and, thereby, let you write up
these applications for greater
scalability, as we
had talked of before.
So given this
context, I would like
to now invite Bart,
who's a customer trying
to build an image
rendering application,
and he wants to check if Google
can help him in using a task
queue in the process.
BART HAZER: If I'm
a developer breaking
my monolithic application
to microservices,
does Google have anything
that helps me minimize the end
user latency?
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Yes, we do.
BART HAZER: Can I fork off tasks
to be done in the background?
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Yes.
BART HAZER: So it's
essentially like threads
from a microservices?
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Exactly.
BART HAZER: I can do
this programmatically?
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Yes.
BART HAZER: Does
it support Java?
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Yes.
BART HAZER: Python?
BART HAZER: Go?
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Yes.
BART HAZER: Node.
BART HAZER: That
sounds really cool.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
And we have a product, and
it's called Cloud Tasks.
It's generally available today.
Please check it out.
The product page is amazing.
It has all our use cases listed.
Furthermore, to talk
about Cloud Tasks,
I would like to invite Braden
on stage from Vendasta,
and his journey on Cloud Tasks.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADEN BASSINGTHWAITE:
Thank you, Vinod.
We're excited to be here.
All right.
I'm Braden Bassingthwaite.
I'm the chief
architect at Vendasta.
And I wanted to
just give you a kind
of brief overview
of our experiences
with Cloud Tasks over
the years of our company.
And so I also want to
talk about how we also
did uniform task scheduling
with BigQuery, as well as Cloud
Tasks.
So to just kind of give you a
brief introduction to Vendasta,
we're in Saskatoon,
Saskatchewan up in Canada.
And we build a
white label platform
for companies that sell digital
solutions for local businesses.
So for the purposes
of this demo,
you can just really think of--
we build products
for local businesses,
whether that's restaurants
or doctors or maybe
car dealerships, just
a local business.
And so we've been
around for 10 years now.
And when we started
as a company,
it was really about the
time that App Engine
was released by Google.
And so ever since then, we've
been an App Engine customer,
but even just more
as a GCP customer.
And we've really utilized
all the products.
We probably use them all,
maybe except for Genomics.
And in kind of the
last couple of years,
we've been migrating from
this App Engine, Python, Cloud
Datastore.
And we probably have
15 of these projects.
And we've now decided to embrace
Kubernetes Engine, Go lang,
and Cloud Spanner.
And so over the
last two years we've
deployed and shipped
75 of these services.
And so something
that's really core
to the identity of our
company is that we really
rely on Google to offer
us managed solutions,
so whether that's for databases
or infrastructure, everything.
We don't have our own servers.
We've never had our own servers.
We've always relied on the
cloud for our business.
And so Cloud Tasks has been an
important part of App Engine.
And just until recently,
we didn't this ability
to use Cloud Tasks, until just--
as Vinod is releasing
an alpha for being
able to push to non
App Engine targets,
which was very exciting for us.
It's been a missing
tool kit for us.
And so the history with our task
queues is, being an App Engine,
if you're not
familiar with that,
is that everything
always gets put in
through as an HTTP request.
You can't spin off background
requests or background work.
Everything's always coming
on that HTTP request.
And for these requests,
you have a 10 minute limit.
And so when you're
thinking of all the work
that you might need to do for,
maybe you're generating billing
reports, or any of
these complex workflows,
you have to think about how
you can divide that work
and actually finish it
within a 10 minute window.
And so it really
forces people to think
about separating these
pieces out and running them
with Cloud Tasks.
And so this is really no
different than running
applications on
Kubernetes Engine.
For us, we're shipping code
to these services dozens
of times a day across many--
countless of them.
And so as pods are
spinning up and down,
if you have long lived work,
that just doesn't really work.
And so you have to have a
way to check in your states,
or gracefully handle
restarts, and as pods
are spinning up and down.
There's just countless ways
that pods can come up and down.
And so for us, we've really
always leveraged frameworks
in order to do this.
The very first one that
we wrote was Fantasm.
And it's a way to
run finite state
machines on Python and App
Engine with Cloud Tasks.
And then Google
released a framework
called Pipelines, which is
also for Python, App Engine.
But instead of it being a finite
state machine, it's more a DAG
based--
maybe like Apache Airflow--
but also with
components for doing
that produced kind
of applications.
And then just recently
we've begun work
on a new framework for running
Go lang Kubernetes Cloud Tasks
frameworks.
And we're going to be opening
source to that very shortly as
well.
So some of the things that
we've learned over the years
is that task queue
is a, at least,
[INAUDIBLE] for execution.
And so we might see over
like a billion tasks
that you might have maybe
a couple of duplicates
that happen.
And so when these
things happen, you
have to make sure that your
application is idempotent.
Otherwise, you're going
to have very strange bugs,
and it'll be very, very hard
for you to track those down.
And so typically, these things--
you're very cognizant
when you're writing up
these applications,
and it's more over time
as things are changing
in the code base
and people are changing and
adding that these things become
not idempotent.
So it's very important to
just always remember that.
And then task naming
is another component
that we've really leveraged for
Cloud Tasks-- is that you can
give each task a
name, and that allows
you to prevent duplicates
from being emitted,
but it also just allows
for observability
into your application.
Maybe when tasks are failing
and they're retrying,
it's really nice to be able
to see that there's maybe
a customer identifier, or
just additional metadata
in that name, so that you can
just more quickly figure out
what's actually going on.
Oh, sorry.
Wrong way.
So we have a product--
it's called
Reputation Management.
And so for a local business--
maybe I'm a restaurant--
we have customers
that are leaving us
reviews across various sources.
And maybe it's through
social media or blog posts,
or maybe just someone would
leave a review on a website.
And so we go and
collect this data
and present it to an end user.
And we have millions
of SMBs in our system,
and we have thousands of
these downstream sources.
And this turns
into a lot of work
that we have to do every day.
And so some of these problems is
that we have maybe API limits,
and we have different
integrations
with different partners.
And we need to make
sure that we're
staying under these
limits, but also we
just want to be a good citizen
and not unintentionally DDoS.
Us being on App Engine
and Kubernetes Engine,
it's very easy
for us to scale up
to hundreds and thousands
of instances and nodes.
Not all of these
downstream sites
can handle that
amount of traffic.
And so we end up trying to put
things into their own queues,
but it just becomes very
challenging in having
so many queues and trying
to manage them all.
And so we ended up building
a system called a scheduler.
And really what it does
is it allows the developer
to go and write a
query in BigQuery,
and all of the emitting rows
that come out of that query end
up getting scheduled
into Cloud Tasks.
And so one of the features
that Cloud Tasks offers
is that you can put an
execution time of when
you want that task to run.
And so what this allows
us to do is run this query
and put in a bunch of
different heuristics
on maybe how you want
to schedule them.
And so when we're
looking at segmenting by,
maybe the source
information, we can perfectly
schedule and uniformly across
this highly dimensional data,
across the entire day.
And so we'll end up
having a table that looks
like this, where we have--
this is a table in BigQuery
where we have three businesses,
and then they all want to go
out to the same source to get,
maybe, the reviews.
And so this is maybe a
very simplified version
of that query, but,
really, all it's doing
is we're using the BigQuery
windowing functions,
and we can partition
by the source,
and we can do a bunch of date
math to smear all of the work
that we need to do
across the entire day.
And so this turns out to be
a very uniform amount of work
that we can schedule.
And so you can see here
now that at the end
the day we have a
schedule time, and then we
can emit that into
a task, and then
those could run in the future.
And so it worked out
extremely well for us.
And so this is a graph
here in Stackdriver that--
one of the heuristics
that we've added here
is that, instead of
starting all over the work
at the beginning of the day,
we've, I guess, scattered it,
so that we slowly start
off the amount of work.
So instead of going from 0
to 100 really, really fast,
we'll emit maybe 20% of it to
start, and then another 20%
to start 5 minutes later.
And so this allows us, our
systems, if they're cold,
they can more
naturally scale up.
And so just in
summary, Cloud Tasks
has been pretty
much vital for us
in being able to build
application on App Engine
and in Kubernetes.
And with our scheduling
system, there's
a bunch of different categories
in heuristics that we can do.
We can very optimize
our API usage.
We can do things like adjusting
for cost and our speed.
And we can even group certain
tasks together that might have
a [INAUDIBLE] locality in that
you're just adding an order
by--
onto a column, we can
force certain things
to run next to each other.
And so with that, I'm going
to hand it back to Vinod.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN:
Thank you, Braden,
for the broad overview of
your architecture and your use
cases.
Moving on.
I would like to now do a
more deep dive of Cloud Tasks
and its key salient features.
Specifically, I'm going to
talk about Cloud Tasks being
a point to point queuing
system for asynchronous tasks
across microservices.
To be more specific,
what it provides
you is reliable task offloading.
You can dispatch your
long running tasks.
It's fully managed,
completely serverless and pay
for what you use.
Furthermore, it provides your
important rate limit and retry
controls.
This is very important
in queuing systems
when you have multiple services
one after the other and tasks
need to be dispatched
through those services.
These rates can be
configured and customized
based on your needs
for your system.
I'll elaborate more on that
as we go through this talk.
Furthermore, it
provides flexible
routing with HTTP and HTTPS,
as well as an authentication.
So you can reach any endpoint
within Google Cloud, as well as
your on-prem systems.
So going back to our image
rendering application.
You can now fork off
your image rendering task
to Cloud Tasks in Google Cloud.
And you can do it
reliably, fully managed,
and pay for what you use.
And you can access Cloud Tasks
using various client libraries
across a broad range of
programming languages.
You can also use a Rest API.
Further, you can configure
and monitor the queues
using Intuitive CLI commands.
And we have a really
good monitoring dashboard
that helps you track the
progress of your tasks
in your queue and take
corrective action whenever
necessary.
So now, diving deeper into some
of the features of the product
itself.
Scheduled task delivery
is an important feature
that Cloud Tasks provides.
Imagine you're a company that
has a subscription service
and a user signs up at the start
of the month for a free trial
period.
And at the end of 30 days you
would like to probably send out
a reminder email encouraging the
user to move from the free tier
to the paid tier.
Then when the user signs up,
you can schedule those tasks
30 days in advance to be
triggered by Cloud Tasks,
and you can trigger
a cloud function
to send that email out
at the end of 30 days,
and remind the user
to maybe try out
the paid version of
the product and so on.
Many of our customers use the
product for this use case.
And hence, I wanted
to highlight it out.
The next feature
is rate controls.
And I'm going to spend
a couple of slides
on this as this is important.
So like imagine Cloud
Tasks or any queuing system
dispatching tasks
at a certain rate,
for example, 10 tasks
per second and so on.
You can do it at
that particular rate,
or you could set
configurable parameters
and then cut down the
rate to maybe a lower rate
and dispatch it at that rate.
Why is this important?
For example, in
queuing systems, assume
that you have a bunch
of services stacked one
after the other and each one
has a different processing
capacity.
So, for example,
here service one
has a capacity of
10 tasks per second,
and service two has a capacity
of five tasks per second.
But if you start
dispatching tasks
at, say, a much higher
rate, then the weakest link
in the chain, then you're going
to reach a state of a system
not being in equilibrium.
You're going to see
a lot of failures.
And then you'll have to take
a lot of corrective actions
to fix that issue.
By having a queuing system that
can help you dispatch tasks
at a configurable rate, the
most optimal link in the chain,
you'll be able to set up
a system for equilibrium.
And the entire flaw in
the system, for example,
here it's five tasks per second.
For many of you who work in
supply chain systems and so on,
this is very common.
It's very much like
inventory management--
making sure that
each hop in the chain
has the right level
of inventory and it's
processing the throughput
at the right rate.
And this is standard queuing
system practice, but having--
controlling that rate from the
source of the entire system
is very powerful.
And hence, I wanted
to call it out here.
Further, moving on-- having
good retry semantics.
So going back to
the email use case.
At the end of 30 days, if I
were a subscription company,
I really want to make sure that
that email reaches my users.
So I want to make
sure I have really
powerful retry semantics.
I want it to retry many times.
Not only that,
during failures, I
want to make sure that the
time gap between the retries
is minimal.
I also retry for a
certain period of time.
So I can set really intuitive
parameters in Cloud Tasks
to make you achieve that goal.
Similarly, you may have certain
tasks or long running processes
that may not be as
user latency specific
and may be delay tolerant.
For example, if you're
running ML model training
workloads that
dispatch in the night
and then the model is stored
eventually in the cloud,
you want those things to
run, but you don't want--
you may have more
delay tolerance,
so you can set lesser
number of retries,
maybe the intervals switching
the retries are longer,
and you may retry over
a longer duration.
And by having
configurable parameters
to help you achieve
those goals, it's
something that Cloud
Tasks provides you.
Furthermore and lastly,
flexible routing is something
that I've spoken about before.
So Cloud Tasks lets you
reach multiple endpoints
with HTTP, HTTPS, as well as
with OAuth and authentication,
across different services in a
cloud, such as Cloud Functions.
If you have a microservice
running on Kubernetes,
you can reach that.
Further, we've launched
new serverless offerings,
which is Cloud Run and Cloud
Run GKE, in this conference.
If you have your
service running on that,
you can reach there, as well
as your on-prem systems.
By letting you reach these
broad ranges of services
across the cloud and
on prem, Cloud Tasks
let's you enqueue
tasks from anywhere
and reach these services.
So with that, I would
like to now move on
to a demo, demonstrating
some of these features,
and then we can move to Q&A.
So could we move
to the demo slides?
Perfect.
Thank you.
So I wanted to give you a
brief overview of the demo
architecture before I start
demonstrating key use cases.
So what I have here is the same
image rendering application
where in step one a
user submits an image,
these images get
enqueued in Cloud Tasks,
and then they hit an
image rendering service,
which is running on Cloud Run.
Cloud Run is a
service offering which
we launched in Cloud Next.
And the reason I
pick Cloud Run is it
easily scales up and
scales down to zero.
So if you don't have
any requests coming in,
it'll scale down to zero,
and it's truly serverless.
And this particular
image rendering service
pulls up images
from Cloud Storage,
and step three sends
those-- sends the data
to an object rendering
microservice running
on Cloud Run on GKE.
And Cloud Run on GKE is
the Cloud Run experience,
but it's on GKE.
And the reason
I've chosen that is
because I want to do
this processing on a GPU,
because I want to
do it in seconds,
and GKE lets you do that.
You can configure
a GPU node pool
and do very quick processing.
That's the benefit of the cloud.
And the end result is
then eventually stored
in Cloud Storage.
So I wanted to give the
audience an overview
of this architecture before
I step into the demo.
So to start off, I'm going to
start with the base use case.
So what I have is a
Cloud Tasks queue.
Like in the UI dashboard,
I have zero tasks running.
And then it gives
you a brief overview
of the different set of
tasks in your queuing system,
the rate of your
queue and so on.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to basically do
this particular basic task.
So basically I'm going to create
a task which submits an image
and renders it and gives you
the direction that it's a cat.
So the way I'm going
to do it is I'm
going to go into
the demo directory,
start off with my
initialization script,
and then submit a request using
the Python Client Library.
So I have a script, which
makes a Cloud Tasks invocation,
it submits a request to a
URL, which is on the Cloud Run
service, and it mentions
that I want you to render
this particular image.
So I start off with that.
So you see that a
task got created.
I go into the UI and I see--
OK.
It got created, and it
got completed as well.
It was very quick.
So I'm going to do it again.
So you see that it's
very quick on a GPU.
But what basically
it did was it created
a task, the task
started running,
and because it's running
on GPU, it's fairly quick.
And you see that the
task got executed.
And I want to now take
you to the output folder.
And here you have your
cat image rendered,
so the rendering is now in
TensorFlow on the GPU node
pool.
It says that it's a cat.
It predicts it with
99% probability.
So this is the
base use case where
I submitted a task to a
queue, it got processed,
and I see the end result.
Now, I want to
now go ahead and--
Braden talked about
scheduled tasks.
And the task ran
immediately right now,
but what if I wanted to
run it a minute later,
a month later, or so on?
So I'm going to demonstrate
that particular use case.
I'm going to use
the same script,
with the Python Client
Library, but I'm just
going to add a parameter which
says, do it after 60 seconds.
So you submit the same task.
You come to the UI and you
see that the task is created.
It was created 4
seconds ago, but it's
going to be executed
50 seconds from now,
and basically submit it later.
I can set it 5 minutes later,
or go all the way up to a month.
And in the interest
of time, we're
just going to click through.
And you don't need to
wait, you can actually
start running the task
immediately if you want to.
So I'm just doing that
right now as well.
So this is interesting.
So now, we saw that these
tasks were getting created
and each one had a task ID.
This task ID was basically
a number generated ID
that the system generates
to uniquely identify a task.
But what if you wanted to
have your custom task labels
and so on based on your
different workloads?
So we let you do that.
We let you name the tasks.
And I'm going to do
something similar here.
I'm going to submit
the same job,
but I'm going to give it a name.
Let's say, April11-1.
So we created a task.
There you go.
And then you see the
task, but now you
can see that the
task name is actually
the name that I had provided.
And it helps you label tasks.
You can do this for, like if
you have different divisions,
each one has a
different task, then
you can use different task
names for each division
on tasks coming from
that particular division.
So lastly, I ran it
now, but this time I'm
actually going to
delete the task
and take that action
because I want to move on.
So the next step that
I'm going to do is--
in queuing systems,
you always have
something as what you call
a poison pill message,
or a poison pill task.
So it's a task that's
always going to fail.
And I know many of
you, while debugging,
have always tried to find
the needle from the haystack.
And here, what I'm
trying to do is
I'm going to submit
an invalid image,
and this task is
going to always fail.
And I'm going to demonstrate
how task keeps retrying.
that particular failure use
case.
So I'm going to do
that same thing,
but I'm going to submit this
particular invalid image.
The task got created.
And I come to the UI and I
see, OK, already the cloud task
has retried several times.
I've set a very low
retry frequency.
It's 0.1 seconds, so it's
going to keep on trying.
I'm going to say run now.
It's going to fail again.
And this is really useful.
I know root cause analysis
is a key thing that people
look for in queuing
systems, and Cloud Tasks
helps you achieve that.
All these operations that
I've done from the UI,
you can do from the CLI, as
well as the client library.
If you have thousands
of tasks, it
doesn't make sense to the user
UI to do this kind of analysis.
But I just wanted to
demonstrate the power
of this particular product.
So moving on, I'm going
to, again, delete this task
from this queue, and then
I'm going to go back.
So we talked about a lot
of the tasks use cases,
how to create a task and so on.
And we said that we could also
do monitoring and monitoring
from the CLI.
So I'm going to try to
look at the list of queues
in my current system,
see what their state
is, what their max
rate is, how many
[INAUDIBLE] in the
process of a given
time, what is the
number of retry
attempts that they can do.
It's a configuration, but this
particular summary command
helps me display that.
I can go deeper into
a particular queue.
If I wanted to describe
additional details
about a particular queue, I
can do a describe on the queue.
It gives me additional details
on all of the different rate
limits that particular
queue gives you.
For example, the burst
size, concurrent dispatches,
as well as the retry config.
And we talked about a broad
range of retry parameters.
All of them can
be displayed here.
And all of them can be
configured from the CLI.
Now, I'm going to submit a small
batch of tasks to Cloud Tasks
and show you how the system
fairly quickly processes it.
And then I'm going to walk
you through some kind--
so I'm going to submit
a small batch that's
creating a lot of these tasks.
And as we see this, I want to
see how the queue performs,
so you can see that the
tasks have started executing.
It's fairly smooth.
It's fairly quick.
On the back-end
you have Cloud Run,
so that's spinning up
more instances and scaling
up as per the needs.
And because it's processing
on GPU, it's fairly quick.
So [INAUDIBLE] to go to
these microservices using
this particular task queue,
and because this [INAUDIBLE]
task execution, and when
the tasks are not there,
those serverless instances
as well spin down.
So it's completely in the
cloud, as well as serverless,
and that's pretty useful in the
power of this particular tool.
So some of the
tasks have failed,
so you can see that
quickly retrying.
They bubbled up,
identifying the root causes,
the needle from the haystack.
So that's the demonstration
of these use cases as well.
I want to move on with
the demo, but you can
do a bunch of other operations.
I can delete independent
tasks, but I could also
delete all the
tasks in the queue
at one shot using
the purge command.
So that's what I'm going
to do right now to move on
with my demo for
the next use case.
So these are some of the
things that you can do.
It's pretty quick, pretty fast.
And it does a lot of things,
like retry and rate limits.
Now, the next thing that I'm
going to demonstrate is--
so I know that my queue
can dispatch tasks
at a certain rate,
but how do I determine
what is the optimal rate
of this entire system?
And I'm going to run a small
sensory analysis using my queue
with the end microservice.
And what I've done
is I've forcefully
disabled auto scaling at the
end cluster, the GKE cluster,
so it won't scale
beyond a certain point.
I'm going to try to
figure out what the max
throughput of the system is.
And I'm going to experiment
that using Cloud Tasks
and figure that out,
so that I kind of find
the optimal flow of the
system and set the rate
to that particular value.
To start this, I'm going
to start step by step.
I'm going to first set the
rate to a really low value
and set it to one
task per second.
So I'm going to set that.
And along with that
I'm going to start
firing a bunch of tasks,
thousands of tasks
to this particular
queuing system.
So these tasks start
getting created.
It takes about 30 seconds for
all of them to get created.
But as you go, I come into
the UI and I see, one by one,
the tasks are getting cued up.
But the progress is fairly slow.
You can clearly see it.
The rate's like one per second.
Six are completed.
It's fairly slow.
And I know that I can do better.
So how better can I do?
So let's do 10x of what I give.
So let's try to set the value
to maybe 10 tasks per second,
and see if that helps us.
I need to go to the demo
directory once again.
OK.
All right.
So it takes about
a couple of seconds
for the command to
get initialized,
but in the process--
so my goal is to set
it to a higher rate.
And as I set it
to a higher rate--
let's just wait for a
couple of seconds for this
to load as well in the meantime.
So the goal is to set
it to a higher rate
and see if that
particular higher rate is
optimal for Cloud Tasks or not.
And if not, try to see if you
can take corrective action
based on that.
This is quicker in practice.
All right.
I'm going to set it
to a different queue.
All right.
It takes about a minute
for this to set up
because I've set up some QPS
limits based on the engine
dispatch rate.
So apologize for that delay.
Yeah, there we go.
So we got the rate set.
And we see that the
higher rate is set here.
So as this higher rate is set,
what you need to understand
is--
OK, I was doing one per
second, now I've done 10 times.
And this 10 points per second,
this rate is also is good,
but I want to understand,
is this good enough?
And we can see that
at the output queue.
We also see the outputs
getting processed.
But the Cloud Tasks queue
I feel could do better.
And one of the things about
this particular feature
is that it helps you do
a sensitivity analysis.
So we have 10 tasks per second,
and we can go all the way up
to 500, and we want to find
the optimal sweet spot.
So instead of doing
10 per second,
if I wanted to do 100 per
second, I would have to retry--
set the same amount to,
say, 100 per second,
and then see if there are
any errors at that point.
So let me just try to
see if I can do that.
So I've set it to
100 per second.
And now at 100 per
second, we still
see that we're doing
reasonably well.
We are processing tasks
at a certain rate.
We don't see big
stresses in the system.
I can go to the output folder,
and if I do a quick refresh,
I see that the output
is getting populated.
So what does this imply?
So this cloud task
is doing really well,
how do I know if I
can set a higher rate?
Is that higher rate
really much better?
Can I do like five times
this particular value?
Can I set it to 500
per second and so on?
So the only way to do that is
you experiment with that value,
and then you try to see
if there are errors,
and then you kind of figure
out your optimal sweet spot
with that particular experiment.
So I'm going to now set the
same thing to 500 per second.
So if we come back here
and set it to 500 second,
there are a lot of
tasks in the queue,
and there are a lot of-- the
tasks are getting processed.
But you can certainly see that
there's been a sudden change.
You see some errors popping up.
You see some kind of failures.
The rate at which it was
processing at 100 versus 500
seems to be different.
And this basically can
be illustrated further
by looking at a
list of the tasks.
You can do that through the CLI.
So I'm going to do
a list of the CLI.
I'm going to list all
the tasks from the CLI.
And then we've got to see
if there are any errors.
So let's just do that.
So what I've done
is I've just run
a command which
lists all the tasks
in the queue at this point.
And you can see at this point
where we have a lot of errors
all over the place,
these internal errors.
So I set a much higher
rate for the queue,
and I figure out, oh, OK, this
is probably not the right rate.
So basically now I
need to step back
and then set it
to a value, which
is basically what I thought
was an earlier optimal value.
And the reason I was
able to replicate this
is because I had
forcefully set the end
cluster to not scale further.
So I had reached the capacity
of that particular system.
And then my sensory
analysis helped
me find out the optimal rate
for this particular queue.
And that's pretty much
what helped me figure out,
OK, I can do 100 QPS
and I should be fine.
If later on something
comes up where
I need to reduce it further,
increase it further,
I can configure it and take
corrective action as necessary.
So that was the demo.
Could we switch back
to the slides, please?
Great.
So just a quick recap as well.
So when I created
that rate limiting
problem, and the place
where I had created the--
I disabled auto scaling was the
object detection microservice.
If you have any other service
where you have such rate limit
concerns, like if
you're hitting an API,
or where there are
API limits and so on,
you probably need to have
some kind of rate limiting
from your source to make sure
you don't reach those APIs
limits for cost saving
purposes, or even,
in this case,
scalability purposes.
The corrective action I took
was I reset the rate limit.
But you could actually do
something else as well.
You could double the
capacity at your end service.
You could double
your GPU node pool.
You could do vertical
scaling and move from a GPU
to a higher GPU.
And you can then drain all
the tasks from your queue.
It all depends on
the user's needs.
Like, if there are
two personas who
are using this
particular product,
one is a user who is enqueueing
tasks from an application
perspective, and a sysadmin
persona who's actually
monitoring the
queue, the sysadmin
can take corrective
action depending
on what needs to be done.
He can increase capacity, or
he could limit rate depending
on the need of the [INAUDIBLE].
So moving on, I
wanted to summarize.
Cloud Tasks is a
point to point queuing
system for asynchronous tasks.
It offers great features,
such as rate limits,
retry controls,
dynamic scheduling,
dynamic HTTP targets
across different services
in the cloud, as well
as on-prem systems,
and it provides your
HTTP with authentication.
[MUSIC PLAYING]